I truly am a lightweight but like what I
had three scoops of ice cream in Chelsea
I'm a video producer in New York and I'm
on my way to tipsy scoop a place that
combines both ice cream and alcohol two
of my favorite things
[Music]
just tried a bunch of the flavors they
were all delicious and now I'm gonna
bring them back and see what my
co-workers think drank alcohol and then
like had ice cream but I've never like
come find him hoping that we can find a
really good intersection I love ice
cream and I love booze but definitely
try it
[Music]
wish I could swirl this like it was a
cool it kind of looks like a frosty
chocolate whiskey I like both of those
things okay I don't know I don't like
whisky this is really good
dink chocolate and whiskey's a good
combination ever thought about combining
the two before really good it tastes
like that bourbon flavor you get in food
that's made with dark liquors it's not
super overpowering I guess which is good
I also don't really believe you there's
alcohol in this so be funny in like an
ice cream cake at a birthday party turn
up at the playground so this definitely
gives me more of coffee cream kind of
look good almost tastes like a coffee
like martini tastes like a frozen White
Russian Irish cream hey that was an
Irish like sound effect but it doesn't
look like it's gonna be strong yeah it's
like vanilla ice cream that will also
get any [ __ ] that there's like a
hazelnut or something in here that that
definitely kind of helps like cope with
the coffee bean flavor I wouldn't order
a Cola drink but like I would buy this
our judgment is gonna get slowly skewed
really [ __ ] excited are you feeling
so margarita absolute hell yeah this is
better than a lot of frozen margaritas
I've had in like bars that's good that's
really goddamn good
how'd you feel at all that was strong
yeah I think that one tastes the most
like alcohol it tastes kind of like an
orange creamsicle good balance of mango
and tequila for sure I think we both
liked that one a little too much this is
actually militia this is really really
good it's good but I don't think I want
a lot of it
doesn't taste like I bought all like
those Italian ICS but like in a delta
time I see okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
0.0 I got plenty I can drive home
I got point oh but zero point zero at
zero point zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero point oh seven haha that's insane
uh I love this this is not a choice not
force to do this
I just wish maybe it was a little more
heavy-handed but maybe there's a little
more bang for your buck maybe with a
shot or more alcohol on top for sure
would like eat whenever the hell I want
to get drunk not wanting people know
that was gonna drunk so these were
really good it tasted like ice cream
that also gets you wasted you had
anything to drink today it's like whoa I
had a lot of ice cream officer
[Music]